نقلت وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه عن مسؤولين
اوروبيا قوله ان المرحله الخطيره من الحرب
في اوكرانيا قد بدات واضاف ان هناك اكثر
من 300 الف مقاتل روسي متجمعين لشن هجوم
لافتن الى انه على الاوروبيين مساعده
القوات الاوكرانيه على المقاومه واكد
المسؤول الاوروبي ان الاتحاد الاوروبي يضع
هذا الاسبوع اللمسات الاخيره على خطه
بقيمه مليارين يورو لتمويل مشتريات مشتركه
من ذخيره المدفعيه التي تحتاجها اوكرانيا
بشده لمواجهه القوات الروسيه ويفترض ان
يتيح المشروع تزويد القوات الاوكرانيه بما
لا يقل عن مليون قذيفه من عيار
155 ملم وتجديد المخزونات الاستراتيجيه
للاتحاد التي اقترب بعضها من النفاذ
لكن مسؤولا اوروبيا قال انه هولندا
وايطاليا لا تزال لديهما تحفظات ولكن لا
توجد عرقيل بهذا الصدد كما قال